previously on another dead man walking
I've been talking regularly to Richard
Glossip who's on death row
despite insisting he's innocent man is
unbelievably decent he came across as
very genuine I'm Ian woods this time why
his supporters have cause for
celebration and how gossip went from
relative obscurity to take center stage
in the national debate about the death
penalty at a certain point we don't want
to pay for that person to be alive
anymore
here's the deal she's not gonna let more
than four people in it's January the
28th the eve of Richard Glossip
scheduled execution family and friends
have come to Oklahoma State Penitentiary
in McAlester to see him with
expectations rising that he will be
granted a temporary stay they don't know
whether they're here to say hello or
goodbye blossoms daughter has flown from
Maryland the breakup of his marriage
meant they'd lost touch I was 13
about 20 what do you think it's gonna be
like in there I just hope he's proud of
to see me like I'm gonna be so proud to
see them and he's super strong man
she and Glossop's nice Billy Joe boy
Adele were wearing t-shirts with his
face and the slogan
please help free an innocent man we've
tried to get people involved he's a
death row inmate he's guilty but he's
not and now everybody's actually
listening in there
they're bringing it out rules are
relaxed on the eve of an execution
they're able to meet Richard Glossip
face to face rather than with bars under
glass screen to separate them also
visiting are his friend and campaigner
from New York
Kim Van Atta and his wife Mary another
campaigner
crystal Martinez and sister Helen
Prejean the nun whose story of working
with death row prisoners became the
movie dead man walking I waited for news
outside the door of the prison's death
row build oh god it's so happy and
everybody's talking at one time he's so
happy a stay of execution had been
granted the US Supreme Court would hear
the case against the use of lethal
injection at the end of April anybody
words so it was great to get to stay and
it was great that that issue was finally
going to be before the Supreme Court
what a day this is a little taste of
what heaven it's gotta be like it was a
celebration it was a party wasn't it we
can breathe again it was a good day an
innocent man was 20 almost 24 hours away
from execution I mean that shows you how
serious this could have been it was also
clear to me that the guards that we were
with none of them wanted to be with
Richard I got to meet sister Helen
Prejean for the first time and when she
walked in the room it was like it's hard
to explain but it was like this calm
came over me that I've never felt before
in my family started coming in for sure
in the last 20 years but now the focus
moves away from Richard Glossop's
personal story to the wider issue of how
the state wants to kill him lethal
injection has long been the method of
choice replacing hanging shooting and
the electric chair it was deemed to be
more humane but as pharmaceutical
companies realized their drugs were
being used
to end rather than prolong life they
began imposing restrictions on their use
I contacted one of them lund Beck is
based in Denmark and it's epilepsy drug
depend to barber tall had been used to
sedate prisoners at the start of the
execution process the company agreed to
talk to me but it is a long way to go
for one interview so I put it to one
side in the hope there would be another
a Danish story in the next few months
that would give me good reason to go
incredibly just a week later I find
myself in Copenhagen reporting on two
shooting incidents involving an Islamic
militant I made time to fit in a visit
to Leung Beck's headquarters before
catching my flight home and spoke to
under Saul we have never been providing
pentobarbital by purpose for prisoners
so of course it was quite a shock we are
a company conducting research to save
people lives with severe brain diseases
so this was from our view the complete
opposite so when you found out that it
was being used what was the company's
response from the beginning we were
against it as I said it's a clear
mission for us to improve people's lives
and we saw that as asset so what we
could do from the beginning was sending
letters to the prisons and we urged them
to stop them issues of our product with
a cooperative were they not cooperative
we never heard back from them so they
just ignored your letter they they
ignored us you know you have other
situations where you have misuse of
medication when people using medication
for doping and here if that's the case
you can work with authorities to try to
stop it but in this case it was actually
the authorities that was doing the
misuse the company restricted
distribution of pentobarbital and then
the European Union banned the export of
drugs which could be used in executions
eventually American prisons had to find
alternatives or get compounding
pharmacies to replicate those they could
no longer get their hands on a drug
called my dazzling took the place of
pentobarbital but it quickly became
controversial because critics
it isn't strong enough to properly
anesthetize a prisoner before the
subsequent drugs which paralyze and then
kill as evidence they cited executions
in Oklahoma and Arizona where the
process took longer than it should have
done
Robert Dunham runs the death penalty
Information Center you've got inmates
who are conscious
you've got inmates who are gasping one
of the descriptions was that the inmate
was flopping around like a fish against
the restraints that's someone who is
clearly experiencing high levels of pain
and we know that the the lethal drug is
akin to being burned from the inside out
here's one of Richard gossips attorneys
mark Henrickson for better for worse
than the death penalty was carried out
with lethal injection for many years
without very many spectacular misfires
and as a result of the unavailability of
penal marbet all the government's have
started experimenting on human people to
try to kill them with other drugs
Oklahoma has chosen midazolam which is
what they used in the Box execution of
Clayton Lockett earlier
last year there have been other
instances throughout the country where
executions were lengthy it appeared that
the condemned was suffering gasping and
conscious and that does not pass
constitutional muster and we should not
use these human beings as Lab Rats for
Oklahoma's attempt to find a
constitutionally acceptable death
penalty protocol and that's why we're
suing about that now you may be thinking
hang on a minute you've only spoken to
people who are anti-death-penalty
and who were supporters of Richard
Glossip well believe me I've tried time
and time again to speak to those on the
other side of the debate over the past
eight months I've spent a lot of time on
the phone and inside the office of the
Oklahoma governor arguing with her press
officer about why she should do an
interview about this my request was
rejected I was told to ask the state's
Attorney General Scott Pruett his press
officer said no and suggested I tried
the district attorney guess what he said
no - I've tried charm
I've tried reasoning with him I've even
tried to shame them into talking to me
by posting comments about the refusal on
Twitter but to no avail
sure they've issued statements and
tweets about the Glossop case saying
essentially that justice has run its
course but they won't discuss the death
penalty at all the only person who
agreed to talk with state senator Ralph
shorty as people Oklahoma overwhelmingly
support the death penalty recent and
even older polls show that it's 75 plus
percent issue where the people of
Oklahoma want you know if it goes
through a proper process and the person
is dedicated properly and that is the
sentence that's brought down then then
they want that person to no longer be a
part of society
I support the lethal injection I support
hanging I support you know whatever it
takes if the state deems is necessary to
effect that death and if it got to a
point where we didn't have the
technological advancements to have
lethal injections and I would support
hanging or beheading or whatever it
would take to make sure that that person
in the end meets his justice until the
colleague came up with an alternative
and succeeded in getting it voted into
law death by nitrogen gas it's very
effective it's cheap nitrogen is
abundant so the 8% of the world
atmospheres nitrogen so you know our
bodies are used to it
so whenever a nitrogen that's applied to
the human being there's no rejection
method from the nitrogen your body
doesn't try to reject what the nitrogen
is offering but when you start reducing
the oxygen levels and the nitrogen
overcomes the oxygen levels then base
what happens is your brain just stops
functioning and your brain stops
functioning the rest of your body stops
functioning as well so it's very
effective it's very cheap
it's very painless can you name some of
the other countries that are
practitioners of the death kind of you
around the world you know I don't think
I could you know not without not without
looking through a list or something like
that if I tell you that it's Saudi
Arabia North Korea Iran China are you
happy for the United States to be a
member of that exclusive club well I
don't think it I don't think that
changes what the purpose behind the
death penalty is I also don't think
that's simply because you know a third
world country or a dictatorial dicted or
dictatorial country is one that employs
that that thing is that somehow it's a
mark on us our people have chosen that
this is a way to remove somebody from
society they've also said inherently
that at a certain point we don't want to
pay for that person to be alive anymore
Richard Wilson did not actually kill
anyone does that bother you that he
could still I'm not sure I'm not aware
of the case you'll have to Richard
Glossip was not the actual killer he's
accused of paying the actual killer
Justin's need to save his own life did a
plea deal yeah now he is serving a
prison sentence the man he blames for
inciting him or paying him to do the
crime gets the death penalty does that
seem like justice well seems like they
should both be put to death it I mean it
would seem to me like you know justice
was served on one end and justice has
not been served on the other naturally I
was keen to fly from London to
Washington for the US Supreme Court
hearing on April the 29th and persuaded
the boss to send me to the States for a
couple of weeks to cover a colleague's
leave but as often happens the news
agenda intervened a couple of days
before the court date
Baltimore erupted in riots following the
death in custody of a young black man
so 12 hours before the hearing was due
to start I find myself being tear gassed
as police tried to clear the streets
but the rioting subsided and I was able
to get the early morning train from
Baltimore to Washington I used to live a
few blocks from the imposing Supreme
Court building and walked past it most
days without ever having reason to go
inside this was my first hearing we'll
hear argument first this morning in case
14 79 55 glossop purses gross miss
Conrad
mr. Chief Justice and may it please the
court the court has quaint rules like
male reporters must wear a tie and staff
are constantly telling you to but the
supreme formality of the place quickly
disappears once the justices start
arguing seasoned observers said the
lethal injection debate was the most
Teti for years let's be honest about
what's going on here executions could be
carried out painlessly there are many
jurisdictions there are jurisdictions in
this country there are jurisdictions
abroad that allow assisted suicide and I
assume that those are carried out with
little if any pain Oklahoma and other
states could carry out executions
painlessly now this Court has held that
the death penalty is constitutional its
controversial as a constitutional matter
its are only as controversial as a
policy matter those who oppose the death
penalty are free to try to persuade
legislators to abolish the death penalty
some of those efforts have been
successful they're free to ask this
court to overrule the death penalty but
until that occurs is it appropriate for
the judiciary to countenance what
amounts to a guerrilla war against the
death penalty which consists of efforts
to make it impossible for the states to
obtain drugs that could be used to carry
out capital punishment with little if
any pain
that's Justice Samuel Alito and you can
tell where he stands on the death
penalty one of the liberal members of
the bench justice Elena Kagan raised
concerns about my dazzling being
inadequate for the job people say that
this potassium chloride it's like being
burned alive we've actually talked about
being burned at the stake and
and and and everybody agrees that that's
cruel and unusual punishment so suppose
that we said we're going to burn you at
the stake but before we do we're going
to use an anesthetic of completely
unknown properties and unknown effects
maybe you won't feel it maybe you will
we just can't tell and and you think
that that would be okay but no point was
Richard gossips individual case
mentioned or were there any remarks
about his plea of innocence this was not
about him even though his life was at
stake this case was about the legality
of how to kill him the arguments lasted
more than an hour and afterwards
Oklahoma's attorney General Scott Pruett
took questions from reporters outside
the state doesn't sentence anyone to
death its responsibilities to carry out
the administration of the death penalty
here the state of Oklahoma since the
late 1970s actually was the state that
birthed and gave life to the lethal
injection process it's the most humane
way to carry out capital punishment
pentobarbital so didn't on pintle had
been used in the past if we had access
to those we would use those drugs we do
not Richard called me the following day
I'm going to call him Richard from now
on rather than Glossop by now we'd spoke
in a number of times so it's
disingenuous to pretend that we haven't
established a relationship where we call
each other by our first names
he has my phone number on his approved
list of people he can ring he reverses
the charges so he calls me regularly
occasionally I record them for broadcast
he'd read the transcript of what was
said in the Supreme Court and he was
angry and they go in with that opinion
on their mind you know they're for the
death penalty and they're not going to
hear anything just going to change their
mind about that the problem with that is
you're a judge in the highest court in
in the United States and you're supposed
to hear the facts of the case and then
rule on the facts of the case and in
this instance I don't think that was
done so you don't think they had an open
mind I mean they made that pretty clear
the Supreme Court decision wasn't
expected to be made public for two
months Richard was in limbo until then
the verdict or the opinion of the court
as it's formally known came on June the
29th by a narrow five to four majority
the court upheld the use of lethal
injection
I heard the news while I was in Tunisia
reporting on the massacre of tourists
ensues Richard phoned me from the prison
as I stood over Luke in the
Mediterranean Beach he refused to see it
as a setback Stephen Brer one of the
four justices who opposed lethal
injection wrote a lengthy paper saying
it was time for a fresh debate on
whether the death penalty was
constitutional but it made no difference
to Richard Glossip just over a week
later Oklahoma announced a new execution
date September the 16th next week we
look at Richards murder conviction and
ask with only the testimony of the
killer
why did jurors find him guilty
you